or more on this potentially historic
weather event we go to meteorologist
jeff beridelli jeff uh
still waiting to figure out exactly how
many people died it's tragic no matter
what that number is but we're talking
about here potentially the first ef5
tornado in the u.s in eight years and
potentially
the longest track of a tornado in u.s
history these are things we won't be
able to verify until probably later
today or tomorrow but it may have been
on the ground maybe for 250 miles the
old record 220 miles we haven't seen an
ef5 in around eight or nine years that
would mean winds could be over you know
250 300 miles an hour with this
particular cell that was on the ground
for four
states so this is going to be an
historic tornado outbreak one of the
worst we have seen in the nation's
history so first i want to bring this up
and show you the big picture
very heavy snow in the upper midwest and
a lot of severe weather to the south
whenever you see this kind of setup a
lot of warm air a lot of cold air
colliding it tends to be an explosive
setup and that's exactly what we saw
take a look at how many tornado reports
we had overnight about 33 so far and
counting
and the strongest one went through four
states
quad state tornado is what it's being
called right now could have been on the
ground 250 miles and take a look at that
debris lofted into the atmosphere seven
miles high so that is an impressive
storm so what could have caused this
well i have to tell you the amount of
warm air that pushed north into this
storm is very rare for december it's a
symptom of climate change oh and by the
way we have a la nina and it's typical
during la nina's that we see tornadoes
in this general area
30 in minneapolis 80 in memphis that
collision zone is where we had enough
instability for the severe weather at
the same time what we had right there
i'm going to put it on over uh to the to
the weather wall and show you take a
look at the surface southerly winds in
the upper level southwesterly winds that
caused the spin in the atmosphere and
that was the very volatile atmosphere
one more thing i want to show you this
is going to continue to move east it
will produce severe weather today but
not nearly as severe but take a look at
these temperatures in places like you
know new york city today by the end of
the day we'll be well up in the upper
50s and mid 60s so a very warm day and
then behind the front much colder air
is going to be moving on in and that's
not it along the west coast we're going
to see a huge atmospheric river guys and
it looks like a very volatile few days
along the west coast with heavy rain and
heavy snow maybe six feet of snow in
this year in nevada all right jeff thank
you very much of course we're going to
continue to keep people up to date and
monitor the aftermath of these storms
all day and also on our streaming
station cbsn so tune in for the latest
obviously those pictures right now in
darkness
once light hits things may certainly
change